francisco franco pas m'en demander entre
dans sa dernière demeure novembre 1975
le général espagnols franco est intérêts
dans le mausolée du valle de los caidos
au nord-est de madrid
un monument imposant pensé par l'ancien
dictateur est construit sous ses ordres
par vingt mille prisonniers politiques
aujourd'hui le gouvernement espagnol a
décidé d'exhumer et de déplacer la
dépouille de franco
car dès le départ cette immense mausolée
a été le symbole du fascisme espagnol un
symbole trop encombrant aujourd'hui en
plus de la dépouille de franco
il y a aussi le fondateur du parti
fasciste qui est intérêts le général
franck où sera inhumé aux côtés
d'antonio primo de ribera fondateur de
la phalange dès les premières années ce
mausolée a donc été le lieu de
rendez-vous des nostalgiques du fascisme
il venait le 20 novembre date
anniversaire de la mort de franco
exemple en 1985 et général franco le
shadow mené pendant plus celle née à
beaucoup de tranquillité dpd gaieté et
en 2005
l'espagne la banque aura conduit
l'espagne en avant nous a donné du
travail à nous avons bien vécu
on doit penser à lui comme une grande
figure de l'espagne et le salut fasciste
était même appris aux enfants qui n'ont
connu ni la guerre civile ni le régime
dictatorial saluer c'est mon respect à
mon général franco c'est elle qui a
sauvé l'espagne du communisme c'est le
salut fasciste
évidemment c'est de faire du fascisme
moi je suis raciste ces rassemblements
deviennent embarrassant pour l'espagne
alors un 2007 le gouvernement vote une
loi interdisant l'apologie du régime
fasciste conséquence déboulonnage des
statuts à la gloire de franco et
interdiction de se rassembler sur la
tombe du défunt dictateur ici depuis 32
ans
ces derniers fidèles lui rendent hommage
mais c'est l'ultime pèlerinage à la
valle de los caidos une loi dite de
mémoire historique interdit désormais
tout rassemblement politique sur ce
monument mais malgré cette loi le
mausolée est resté un lieu de culte pour
les admirateurs de franco c'est pourquoi
le gouvernement a décidé de déplacer la
dépouille afin que ce monument ne soit
plus le symbole du fascisme
[Musique]